mais après cette demande d'explication
de la part de la france et de
l'allemagne quelles sont les réactions
pour plus de précision on retrouve ont
tout de suite notre reporter thomas
bonnet en direct de washington bonsoir
thomas 48 heures après les révélations
de la presse européenne sur cette
complicité danoise lors des coupes de
dirigeants européens tous vous aucune
réaction de la maison blanche
donc c'est silence radio après la
parution de ces informations et ce
malgré les demandes d'explication lancé
par la france et l'allemagne alors joe
biden était concentrée ce lundi sur le
jour férié ici aux etats unis le
memorial day est aujourd'hui en
déplacement at you ça dans l'oklahoma et
puis de son côté le chef de la
diplomatie anthony blinken est en
déplacement au costa rica alors ces
accusations ont quand même été relayée
par la presse américaine on y découvre
notamment que la haine et ça ne souhaite
pas donner suite aux demandes
d'interview qui ont été formulées par ci
par là presse américaine il ya toutefois
des experts selon des anciens des
services de renseignements qui sont
interrogés dans ses articles les
minimise un peu en expliquant que c'est
tout à fait normal à d'espionner ses
alliés on peut se demander pourquoi
coredi ces experts si ces accusations
avaient été de fait de la russie ou de
la chine par exemple en tout cas cette
affaire est embarrassante pour joe biden
qui on le rappelle était vice président
au moment des faits en 2013 lors des
premières révélations faites par edouard
stodden barack obama avait déjà dû
répondre aux interrogations voire aux
accusations il faut se souvenir qu'à
l'époque
angela merkel avait appelé directement
le locataire de la maison blanche barack
obama à l'époque pour lui demander des
explications
alors quelles conséquences aura pour les
relations entre l'union européenne et
les etats unis
mais c'est justement ce qu'on va pouvoir
mesurer ces prochains jours alors pour
le moment malgré les condamnations reste
sur une ligne plutôt molle du côté des
pays européens il n'a pas mis par
exemple de menaces de sanctions et puis
surtout donc ces révélations
interviennent à quelques jours d'un
déplacement très important pour joe
biden qui va se rendre en europe il y
aura le sommet de l'otan au sommet du g7
et un sommet justement entre l'union
européenne et les etats unis
on verra à ce moment là quelle sera
l'attitude de baden s'il ya des excuses
par exemple et puis on verra aussi si la
confiance a été quelque peu
la meilleure parmi les sujets qui seront
abordés lors de ce voyage il ya
justement des négociations sur un accord
concernant le transfert des données
transatlantique qui doit remplacer un
accord précédent qui avait été invalidée
par l'union européenne en raison
d'inquiétudes concernant des activités
d'espionnage américain on est déjà en
plein coeur du sujet alors les pays
membres de l'union européenne répit
temps assez régulièrement leur volonté
de souveraineté bien ils ont là une
occasion de montrer concrètement au
président américain
la politique qu'il souhaite avoir merci
thomas bonnin en direct de washington